i was drawn to the share the mic now
campaign because i love the concept of
sharing a platform
with amazing women so their voices can
be heard and ignite change through
partnership
and lovie aj jones see i messed it up
again
ajayi jones is the definition of cool
she's been on the show several times she
is one of the co-creators of this
movement
and now she is here as my share of the
mic co-pilot i'm really yours this is
your movement and i've welcomed my side
i've you know put myself in it um so hi
lovey how are you i drew i'm good for 20
20 uh sake
i yes that uh by the way that's a
perfect way to put it
um so you know people say
that um their voices aren't heard
and what do you say to them lovey
i think everybody's voice is necessary
and whether or not people
feel like they're listening you still
must share your story
your perspective and your thoughts in
this world
you have so many incredible women doing
this with you
in fact i um was so lucky glennon doyle
uh was on the show recently and this is
just an amazing movement this is our
third time doing this and i'm so excited
to
celebrate um brandeis uh
daniel is here hello and please welcome
hello francis daniel now 13 years ago
yes welcome hey brandis hey lovey
look i'm not sure which camera i know
we're all over the place
okay so 13 years ago you started um
harlem fashion row yes and tell us about
that
yeah i started 13 years ago i was at a
fashion show in brooklyn and got
inspired and said i want to do this in
harlem that's where i was living at the
time
and as i started to plan for the show i
wanted to feature designers of color
mostly black and latino designers and i
couldn't find them
and so as i started to dig and do more
research i found out that less than one
percent
of designers sold in major department
stores are designers of color
and i was like that was my aha moment
and i was like this is why
i had this idea this is why i've been so
passionate about this so i just started
saying okay i'm going to be a solution
for this
so one of the things that you do which
i'm very familiar with
because you know you sort of talk to
brands and endorsements
you know you do deals as a producer we'd
have you know trade-outs for films we do
it here
brandes is the woman who literally puts
collaborations together i'm going to
tell you about a couple uh right now you
have
nike x lebron just nike and lebron
literally you're wearing the shoes right
now i am
and janie and jack which is this
beautiful children's store
and you did that with kimberly goldson
and banana republic you have a
collaboration coming out soon
amazon music you put dapper dan with to
celebrate culture and history
um bloomingdale's uh fey noel you did a
lion king collection
you are really the person behind when
you know like if i see a beyonce doing
like an ivy park for
uh gosh who is that for um shop
or was it adidas now adidas yeah um
i i think it's now i think she started
in top shop but when you see these cola
i think by the way i could be super
wrong about this when i see these
collaborations come about i'm always
wondering who is behind them
brandeis these are really exciting
things that come out into the world that
we as consumers
can feel inspired by to wear
proud of and now really incentivized
to participate because they're so
meaningful
yeah absolutely it has been honestly
such a gift for me to
really amplify the voices of designers
of color now i wish i was a part of the
beyonce one
i wasn't part of that one but with nike
lebron
kimberly ghost and fee noel and under
celeste like we pulled together the shoe
that sold out in five minutes and that
was the first time
a brand had said we'll bet on these
emerging designers of color who are
incredibly talented
but the whole world don't know and that
opened up the door to the collaboration
with janie and jack which i have a few
things for you girls
really i do oh my gosh i have to admit i
just cleaned out all their closets like
the last few weeks and i'm like that mom
who's like and they were uniforms in
school i'm like
i haven't bought clo thank you i i
actually
could use some thank you i appreciate it
um and then they paint and everything so
i'm not very inspired
to like buy you know it's a whole thing
you're gonna love it
thank you i really really really really
need it i appreciate it um
i just love what you do and when we see
these collaborations come about it's
really nice to know the person behind
igniting that spark and liaisoning it
all
to function out there in the world so
that we can go out and
enjoy and like live in the cool factor
the empowerment
and you know we are consumers and it's
really great when we consume something
really positive
absolutely and important and i mean look
at your shoes they are
so cool but i am prepared that we yeah
i want a pair of those i but i it's it's
rare that we get to see the person
behind the actual coming of it all about
the idea man
so thank you and i'm going to share my
instagram with you you're going to take
it over
all day absolutely i can't wait i'm so
honored to do this with you thank you
i'm so honored and thank you lovey
for this incredible initiative
you're amazing this is our third time i
cannot wait for more thank you lovey to
everything you always bring to the show
our attention and the incredible mission
you're on with share the mic now
it's an honor to be a part of it thank
you guys for having me
thank you
you